hold up à la gare de l'est fric frac à
la caisse de retraite de la sncf
ce pourrait être les sous titre de ce
film que tourne actuellement bernard
blier jean lefebvre michel serrault et
tsilla chelton titre du film c'est pas
parce qu'on a rien à dire qu'il faut
fermer sa gueule date de sortie dans les
salles parisiennes décembre 74 christian
clavier et gérard jugnot deux auteurs
venus du café théâtre en ont écrit le
scénario
l'idée soit hold-up
ça nous est venue parce que à partir du
lieu en fait beaucoup trop chaud c'était
un lieu qui nous semblait intéressant
pour qui s'y passe des choses
dégueulasses vous inspirent les skis en
dessous des gares de l'est les airs les
toilettes ça ça nous a inspirés et alors
on a voulu faire quelque chose dans ce
goût là si on vient en france et sur une
table ça pour être vrai mais pourquoi
pas oui réalisateur du film jacques
besnard pour lui doit déjà le grand
restaurant la belle affaire et le fou du
labo 4 avec déjà le trio bernard blier
michel serrault et jean le fait il donne
ici quelques derniers conseils avant le
tournage d'une scène
public par rapport à la balle aux deux
d'accord
est-ce qu'on se foutait là qu'une
solution c'est métro
michel serrault calé au troll qui jouez
vous dans ce film qu'est ce que je fais
mon nom
non franchement je crois c'est un
malfaiteur s'est pas dans le fond je
m'appelle max c'est tout ce que je sais
je suis en beauce et par
embauché par monsieur fall o c'est tout
ce que je fais dans la vie vous êtes le
cerveau de
cerveau c'est beaucoup dire vous avez
imaginé là bas
un hold up un peu particulier s'ils sont
trois malheureux petits enfants un hold
up très important combien vous avez
avec la dévaluation et le sait pas
exactement quand je suis nous sortira on
peux pas vous dire exactement ce que ça
donnera mais c'est beaucoup d'argent et
qui peut exploser
oui la vie est pas loin d'un milliard
peu comme une forme que vous êtes un
petit peu le sol à sabou fait rien je
vais vous dire franchement je crois
qu'ils m'ont mis au point du scénario je
croyais que c'était un court métrage sur
les gars parce qu'on va tourner un gars
de l'est gare du nord gare saint-lazare
gare montparnasse
j'avale et les invalides en fait forcé
voilà que dans sérieusement c'est un
safina 6 en ligne
pourquoi parce qu'il sera dans d'abord
devait il ne le fait pas l'air d'avoir
parce que je suis d'un ça sera très long
parce que ya du suspense il ya de la
poésie et de l'attendre il ya de la
beaucoup de tendresse film moment et
pour une fois il n'ya pas de cul ce qui
est très important à l'heure actuelle
vous pouvez nous dire un peu votre
personnage c'est un tendre malfaiteurs
comme mémé c'est un grand nord
malfaiteurs ils qui veut soulager la
société
il veut soulager la sncft vidéo ils ont
dans leur corps alors et alors avec le
supplier qui est la tête
témoin le temps et moi le tronçon jérôme
forget on fauche mais c'est simple de
passer assez particulier ce sera un très
beau film ça sera pas des comics mais
bon c'est sur un film que l'on n'aura
jamais vu
je pense à 121 côté dégagé le
stationnement est interdit
avec don privé ce fut les cuisines au
musée d'agen mais pas ni diotte contre
121 à cinématique du oui nous allons
chercher une dépanneuse on régresse
couleur bleue fait dix fois par jour
qu'est ce qu'il à votre véhicule c
les moeurs cwi